You may remember from the consciousness lesson, when we discussed the potential
effectiveness of MDMA in treating post-traumatic stress disorder, so now let's
recap PTSD. PTSD often develops after someone is exposed to a terrifying event
that involves physical harm or the threat of physical harm. And someone with
PTSD often feels frightened or stressed. Even when they're no longer in harms
way. Exposure to natural disasters such as hurricanes, tornadoes, tsunami's, or
even earthquakes can cause PTSD. Exposure to war whether or not you're a
soldier, prisoner of war, or even a bystander of war, can result in PTSD. And
physical or sexual assault or even losing a loved one suddenly can result in
PTSD.